wenn nicht altmodisch aber ein staat der
sich zuständig fühlt wenn mal wieder
schön der sich kümmert
die tun ja so als wären die von
privatleuten organisierten tafeln quasi
ihr verlängerter arm
ich habe mich getrennt und hat mir das
sozialen bekomme ich im zuschuss zur
miete und da hat mir das sozialamt
ruinen hierher zu kommen ja kriegen
rentner immer häufiger zu hören
die läufer zur tafel und sagt das
codewort deutet staatsversagen
immerhin kein politiker der noch bis
drei zählen kann würde sagen dass es
richtig ist ausländer nichts mehr zu
geben
ja der doppel hier der findet das ok das
erstmal nur die zitat dobrindt
angestammte berechtigten was zu essen
kriegen
ich finde es sollte eine tafel geben die
abgelaufene hirn rest an bedürftige
politiker verteilt adobe
wer die gelegenheit verpasst zu
schweigen jetzt macht jetzt mal ohne
witz man kann doch nicht not gegen elend
ausspielen doch kann man hier neues
computerspiel mortal kombat tafel
edition brutales foul gegen arm kämpft
an der schlange vor der tafel als oma
kazaa lag gegen armut aus syrien für
jeden treffer gibt es einen brokkoli
oder du spielst den dobrindt das heißt
tatenlos am rand stehen und dünnschiss
lava mortal kombat tafel edition jetzt
gibt's richtig einige tassen freunde
nicht im heutigen forschung
es gibt verteilungskämpfe am unteren
ende der gesellschaft das ist tatsache
die darf man nicht ignorieren aber das
eigentliche thema heißt ungleichheit
jedes fünfte kind in deutschland ist arm
jedes fünfte kind und das wird vererbt
es gibt regelrechte hartz4 dynastien bei
uns eine stande
kinder deren familie schon in zweiter
generation zur tafel geht und das ist
keine naturkatastrophe freundin ist die
folge von politik denn der ganz große
tafel boom hat eben nicht mit der
flüchtlingskrise angefangen sondern
richtig mit den hartz-reformen 2004/2005
da gab es ein riesen anstieg ist die
tafel und agenda
das gehört zusammen die tafel
deutschland eine einzigartige
erfolgsgeschichte 25 jahre tafel und
bald 9 135 filialen
da wird selbst starbucks grün vor neid
aber dieser armut tun wäre gar nicht
möglich gewesen ohne einen mann
deswegen sagen wir heute danke danke
gärtig töne nicht ich färbe schröder
vater der tafeln
[Applaus]